hey guys it's Gary Vee I've teamed up
with my friends at over New York to take
my engagement to the next level so I'm
announcing that I'm gonna put my book
tour on over near this great new app
great founders and more importantly I've
become very obsessed in 2014 Nate and I
have talked about Nate has been my
former assistant that we co and Jib Jab
Jab Jab right hook and we always talk
about these 40 minutes that I have in
New Orleans or Cincinnati or Cleveland
or you know Memphis you know North
Dakota like in these 20 minutes these 20
minutes that I've got my meetings I did
what I did spoke consulted looked at a
startup and now I've got 40 minutes
before I go to the airport go home cuz
I'm in and out and I always wanted to
have the ability to say hello hi-5 fans
you know take it to that next level
right a tweet doesn't necessarily work
and so you know by the time you speed it
up and organize so what over Nia really
allows me to do is I'm gonna start
putting into this app where I'm gonna be
ahead of time and then it creates a push
notification for people that follow me
and the other people that are gonna jump
on this pretty excited about this it's
really taking my 2014 what I'm calling
is the 2014 engagement tour right like
when I go somewhere I'm gonna put it in
there and hopefully you know say okay
I'll meet a Wendy's you know sonic you
know something like that and just and
meet you there and so hopefully pay
attention
hopefully joining more importantly who
they jump on right away and check out
where my book tour is Portland I'm
talking to you I'm talking to you Tempe
Arizona big upstanders on an eighth New
York New Jersey SF area LA Vegas I might
were the biggest known being just a
speech there right but I'm gonna have
that 20 minutes and so um a big shout
out to over there for team up and really
big she had to over near for creating
the app that I've been looking for